know how to use a gun
yeah yeah
but she shoot everyone who's lonely
[Music]
yeah yeah
and become more
[Music]
I took my own feet out not today so I've
got goosebumps those sense are three
ways
baby
[Music]
laptop ready
no
she really is great that vitamin P you
got last night
oh I've got goosebumps you haven't had
those since we got that swinging chair
foreign
[Music]
go
I'm spinning all over myself oh my God
you two need to get a room that was
great tell me that wasn't great
are you going to Istanbul
you guys are doing a great job only six
more hours
what do you go for huh a fairy tale
fairy tales are for children
[Music]
God I would give up my other eyes spend
one more night looking at you Jones I'm
in the middle of something here
I'm a cyclops can only hear
what I'm on here
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
you basically got it
[Music]